Speaker 1: Welcome everybody. It is a major major
24 hours of news, we have all sorts of different
things going on economically, including what's
going on in the stock market. The expected Fed
announcement today about interest rates, which a
lot of different people are watching for different
reasons, be it geopolitically or economically
or financially or whatever the case may be.
We're also going to be talking about foreign
policy and geopolitics today and just a lot
going on. So to start with really major statement
yesterday from the Department of Justice, there's
been this question for months now which, quite
frankly, to put it coarsely. The question is like,
what the hell is the DOJ doing? Are they going
to investigate any of the dozen different things
that they could investigate related to what
Republicans and the Trump campaign did and tried
around the 2020 election? What is Merrick Garland
doing now? The answer on most of those things is
still no. They're not investigating, but a pretty
major piece of news. Yesterday, an admission from
the deputy attorney general, Lisa Monaco,
who said there is an active investigation
into one element of the Trump coup plot, which is
the fraudulent Republican electors. Now I'm trying
to think, should I play the clip first or should
I explain what that? Let's play the clip first,
where she acknowledges that there is an
investigation going on. Then I'll remind you,
there's so many aspects to the
2020 Trump coup attempt that
I'll explain which one she's referring to.
Speaker 2: On the issue you raised in terms
of a fraudulent elector certification, this has
been reported. We've received those referrals. Our
prosecutors are looking at those at those, and I
can't say anything more on ongoing investigations.
But more broadly, look, the attorney general
has been very, very clear. We are going to
follow the facts and the law wherever they lead
to address conduct of any kind and at any level
that is part of an assault on our democracy.
Speaker 1: So at any level is, of course,
code for up to and including the president.
That's good to see. But specifically,
she says, there is an active investigation going
on into the electoral scam now. Let me remind you,
we have such a in many countries. If we said
the thing they tried with the election is being
investigated, it would be one thing. It would
be like, OK, they tried messing with absentee
ballots or they tried manipulating voting
machines, or they lied to people about what
the voting hours like they would be. We would
know what it is with the Trump attempt in 2020.
It's five or six different things. And the one
that Lisa Monaco is referring to is the idea of
sending an alternate, fraudulent set of electors
to cast votes within certain states for Trump
instead of Biden. So I'll I'll remind you of one
state where they did it. The idea was this Arizona
Joe Biden won Arizona. Not controversial to say
that in the world of sanity, reason, empiricism
and logic, Joe Biden won Arizona Republicans
fixated on Arizona as one of the states where
they said Trump actually won. Now, on
January six, 2021, as we now all know
those electors, those votes were
formally accepted in Washington,
D.C. Some of them carried over into January 7th
because of the riots. The idea that they had was
sign up, create a document that says Here are
the electors from Arizona and they would be
Republican electors, even though Joe Biden won.
Send them to be the ones to say Arizona casts its
electoral votes for Donald Trump. With the idea
that Mike Pence would be the one to say due to the
dispute and fraud and whatever in Arizona, we are
accepting these Republican electors, and instead
of these Democratic electors, it was an insane
long shot. And of course, it didn't happen and
Mike Pence didn't participate. That's the scam,
and it looks like Rudy Giuliani ran that and that
they were trying it in seven or so states. That is
what Lisa Monaco says. Is under investigation, so
that's a good thing. It's a very big deal
and we will continue to follow it. Of course,